yes so Joe and I saw each other in at
the Gary Vaynerchuk show in Rochester
what would you think about would you
think about Gary Vee afters had you seen
him before like would you know about
Gary Vee before and then would you think
you're actually one of my business
partners he's he's in that world like he
used to work with like a lot of
motivational speakers and stuff like
that he put me on him right and then
he's like you wanna you want to get to
know this guy most most of these guys I
don't really like because they don't run
businesses or they don't know what
they're talking about they sell dreams
and stuff mm-hmm
so they sound like like a used car
salesman to me but this dude when I
heard him I was like oh [ __ ] this guy
he's a businessman yeah he he he has his
parents I think it was a liquor store
wine company and he blew it up yeah I
think he had a wine company and then
they like tree he like tripled their
sales once he got like actively like
pushing the business I mean I had a
business to begin with exactly and then
and then the stuff that he says makes
sense and I know this because you know I
owned like a few restaurants yeah and I
have I've been in business for a while
so I'm like all right cool
like I could tell that he's not
bullshitting I like what he's saying
he's straightforward and I think that's
what we need right now we need a guy
that can just be straight about
everything right yeah do you think um
yeah because I watch every you know like
it went when things I watch I'm like oh
is this person you know are they just
giving me information or they somebody
that I could look at as like an actual
guide are they just selling me something
you know those are the things that I
think you know are my natural
inclinations when I'm watching something
like okay is this just for entertainment
yeah is this for entertainment and
education is this just an a hidden
advertisement you know yeah um but yeah
I thought it was interesting I left out
of there I I definitely thought I was
interesting I felt like I get this feat
this vibe and I can be totally wrong
it's just you know most of the vibes I
get her wrong and but that Gary Vai he's
just like so into business though that
it becomes almost like an obsession yeah
okay yeah that's true like that's where
I don't want to be ever in my life I
mean I don't you know I woke up at
probably 10:30 a.m. today so I don't
think I'll ever get into that place but
um I know what you mean it's a
about balance right you got obsessed to
the point where your relationships
suffer when you're totally ready where
you have like yet Miami has like a
hundred million dollars like what does
that even mean
I know I kind of get it because I have
friends like it right and there do you
really yeah the way they see business is
like a video game so they're obscene oh
how some people are super obsessed with
like different hobbies and video games
or like some people want to surf like
ten hours a day or something like that
right and that's the way this guy's
you've mastered a lot of our listeners
gonna masturbate for half and some of
these guys have been sending pictures
and artwork some guy sent me it drawing
the other day allegedly done in you know
skeet or whatever they call it you jack
off onto a piece of paper I didn't see I
didn't see him make the paint you know
what I'm saying but I definitely saw you
know the final artwork in the art wasn't
even any good and I felt bad for looking
at it and then he send me a message I
just look again and see if you like the
picture and I was like and I looked
again because I'm gonna be I don't not
be somebody that doesn't care about
somebody's art yeah you know and it
still was just horrible it just didn't
look like I look like somebody just
honestly masturbating on to uh-oh
hey I think I kind of got tricked but
anyway but yeah some of our listeners
but yeah go on you were saying people do
all kinds of yeah I just think the thing
is like it could be a video game yeah I
think he just he's just passionate about
it right and and but you're right like I
mean sometimes obsessions and passions
can go overboard and it could destroy
people but I think he does it in a in a
more healthy way because he doesn't
preach that hashtag hustle you need to
work all day and do all this stuff if
you really listen to what he's saying
it's really there's a bigger picture to
it and it's about like connecting with
people being right and you in creating
products and businesses that are ethical
and stuff like that right so it's not
really it's not really this like work
all day work all night don't even sleep
you could sleep later mentality right I
think if you love doing anything you'll
do that for farming if you're passionate
about farming you yeah I mean like so I
think it's it's just with money there's
this weird stigma around it like because
there are so many you know shady
scammers and
that stuff that's tied to that kind of
world yeah yeah do um yeah but yeah
you're right I think about that it's
like think about that a lot I guess and
maybe I don't know if I even obsessed
sometimes on that like like what is like
enough are you into business to be doing
business yeah I'm in the business you
know that's I'm entering I'm getting
more into it yeah yeah you know I think
what happened for me was uh
I just started getting busy and so it's
like okay my time is a commodity yeah
yeah you know and it's really the only
come it's like the only like commodity
that's definitely mine yeah um you know
like intrinsically you know or whatever
yeah so it's like you know that buster
has from they are things started like
okay I can't do this anymore I can't do
that like I can have a conversation
that's a you know I can't hang out and
just listen to some of that's drunk talk
for an hour yeah cuz they're not gonna
do nothing's gonna come of it right
nothing's gonna come up for me that's
gonna come out for them yeah you know
just little things like that but it
starts to but then it becomes more and
more serious that's like okay I just
need to be I need to be a little bit
more efficient yeah yeah I mean I a
friend of mine and a long time ago
invested in a in a apartment an
apartment or condominium down in New
Orleans
oh [ __ ] and so that's one thing that I
got into slowly over the years it's been
like 15 years now you know we each had
like 10 grand and then we put in and we
got a place so then over the years like
you become like a you know a property
manager your landlord so you have real
estate you want that world so then I
started to get into it a little bit
right like I started then like over time
you know was able to sell sell and then
get to places right but then also it's
like I've realized in that time like
then now I become a landlord there are
times when I'm a landlord where I'm
seeking tenants there are times where
now part of my you know week I have to
deal with you know like dealing with HOA
issues and all that kind of stuff so
it's yeah I've definitely learned some
of it you know things like that that
make you want to think like okay at
first I'm like well maybe I'll buy an
apartment building one day yeah but do
you want the responsibility that's
another thing right I think that's what
they don't tell you is like they don't
oh this is so cool owning businesses but
like they don't tell you all the
[ __ ] you have to go through yeah
yeah and if you don't and if that's
something
think that's a thing you know I think a
lot of people feel you know we see
videos like business videos online yeah
and some of them make me feel it makes
me feel inspired but then sometimes
Africa I can also feel like oh man I'm
not doing enough you know that's true I
started too late I did this I did that
but some people is business is not for
everybody yeah a hundred percent and
being like am it like that kind of stuff
like dude the other night like I'm in an
HOA call right I'm listening to on a
part of an HOA board and dude I'm
sitting there for two hours listening
while some guy who I think is probably
an alcoholic like just their rates
everyone else on the board you know yeah
but it's like I have to be I have to do
that because I commit it and it's just
yes more business gets created so if you
don't want to be a business person you
don't really like doing those sorts of
things
then just don't feel bad about yourself
if you you know see those types of
videos you know like [ __ ] I'm not a
business guy yeah I mean that's that's
how I that's why I like the Gary Vee
dude cuz he doesn't come off as like a
lot of the other guys right I mean
because you're in business you know yeah
you know like who's a fraud and who
isn't like if someone's just trying to
sell you a dream yeah and they're like
you want to be on this [ __ ] yacht
with a bunch of girls and [ __ ] it's yeah
and they throw one of the girls off the
yacht they're like what would it Belinda
do yeah I mean you're better off trying
to be an entertainer an artist you get
that [ __ ] for real you know like and it
doesn't cost that much if you think
about it you could rent a yacht you get
a bunch of girls want to kill your
brother with a nice gun and he just
killed one of his brothers thankfully
the guy has like nine brothers you know
but it's still like but yes some of its
just delusional
yeah but then there are guys and I did
notice he seemed like I just got to
shake his hand and say hey we chatted
for maybe six seconds and it was uh he
does seem authentic though he seems
authentic in his desire to like lead
people um in and not getting stuck in a
bad habit right that's one thing I
noticed I mean one thing I took away
from what he preaches is like you know
really give away the content don't try
to sell everything all the time yeah and
then be honest with yourself like like
if if you want to make a million dollars
be honest about that don't [ __ ] go
around and say like yeah I want to help
the world I want to do this for charity
or whatever then get into charity right
I mean there's a lot of people out there
that want to get into business and they
think they're saving the world or they
don't want to come off as greedy right
well they're not being honest with them
ah that's internally I was like oh
that's that's totally right thank you
guys for checking out this clip and if
you want to see another clip and you can
look at this clip or this clip either
one of these so did you pick one or he's
still just watching me do this because
this is alarming